time around we stopped having sex
regularly around six months it was not
six months yes it was the end of May
beginning of June
well then it was not regularly already
before
like I brought a bikini too I know I
know which one I know which one you
brought it yes see I listen to you
sometimes Alex makes me feel very
self-conscious right now
I mean he's got a body like it's a freak
of nature he doesn't work out and he
looks that good and I hate him for it
but I can't compare myself to him but I
keep comparing myself to the old Lauren
who is super fit and skinny and looked
good and had a little Peach tush now
forget it
look how fancy honey that's our Cabana
this is our Cabana so our pedicures by
the pool oh I'm hot though I gotta take
this off air the belly out
what is that
thank you honey thank you
watching me get in is probably funny do
I look like I'm feeling sexy right now I
feel like a beached whale you're
beautiful he does not think I'm as
beautiful as ever right now he is not
one of those men that think pregnant
women are beautiful he's like oh wow
your dimples have dimples
yeah but it's okay but it is okay I know
your body goes through everything of
course it's Gonna Change I'm okay with
that and you want to do this again right
away which is insane I don't mind I know
you don't mind your body I mean okay
oh I think our nail Patrol is here nail
Patrol
I've always wanted Alex to get a
pedicure and what a perfect opportunity
because he can't say no to me
I don't know I'm not very excited about
this pedicure I kind of scared of it
you're gonna love it
is anything you have in mind today for
the caller thinking of like white oh I
love this brand Alex what color are you
gonna get black do you have black do you
have black would you like to get a color
give me a color why not are you getting
a color I'm getting black that's it
black yeah no problem
Alex really committed not only did he
get a pedicure he got black polish on
his toes
it wasn't that bad either
but I don't know what I'm talking about
ever
[Music]